welcome to this video playing hoops
something like that yeah this is a
pronounced a French name I'm failing
okay I'm going to play a double
fianchetto here against the Kings Indian
so nice sideline that's not easy to play
for black because he does not get any
five so so easily ok let's see us go
with C 5 may be gassy 5 does make some
sense and connection with 9 a-6
otherwise I'm not so clear what the
night is doing on the edge of the board
when I was taking some time ok so we're
going to reach reach a position normally
from the from the English opening age 6
kind of a nothing move really
not sure what this is is doing ok it's
going for Bishop f5 I could play night
h4 hen night eh for ya baby 7 is hanging
so he needs to retreat maybe I'm I had
something better even but but ok this is
this is ok fine fine position um maybe
d5 yeah it all looks quite good d 52 to
gain space then you cannot easily play 6
cm
yeah let's try to get this big center
using the fact that I can play the F
porn there now five sir is around the
corner yaoi 586 can be very problematic
because of the night on each form okay
so he's retreating him yeah maybe
prepare me five simply ignoring
everything that I'm doing okay maybe he
had no way to prevent it with itself
yeah now he success the problem is 6f in
a g6 or e 60 fe de exposing the g2
bishop okay well this must be right not
going to think he along any longer I
even lets me take on use Excel okay okay
so Bishop g5 winning this material or 95
so both pretty good i'm going with 95
that's hard to tell what's better here
f5s the IDM yeah
okay let's let's take it check check
check now this is made can even take my
the Queen's Essex yeah a real disaster
okay I'm not quite sure why why h6 sent
Bishop f5 should be played look some
really problematic just going back now
okay I'm not sure about g5 though if
this is really the best way to play
maybe keeping the tension is also good
keeping the diagonal open like III
awesomes but okay it's a space advantage
that should count for something going to
prevent be five for the moment a plate
this very slow near would be six and I
wanted to gain some space maybe you
should try not you for here something
like that there are some fun tricks them
but I don't I don't need to take it yeah
running into this trap okay after that I
don't know I mean after you five white
must be close to winning let's see what
the engine is giving to point to where
it is probably impossible to withstand
this this pressure takes yeah and here I
wonder maybe Bishop g5 is even stronger
but this is this is quite okay I guess
yeah plus three is ok yeah just check
and just take him and here the other is
really nothing you can go here but I
still have the check so get the end we
have a have a mate coming after this I'm
going to a check checkmate win with this
cute mate yeah this was an opening
disaster
okay thanks for watching